[SIMULATED FIREWORKS]
You know, chase an answer.
Just don't give up.
I mean, I think you have to have
a love of symmetry, patterns,
colour, enjoyment really of what
you see and what you discover.
My name's Judith Howard.
I'm a chemical
crystallographer working
at the University of Durham.
Crystallographers come from
many different scientific
disciplines.
What we have in common is
the technique that we use
and the methodology, so
that the small samples
that we use-- and these
can be small crystals
of a chemical nature
or a biological nature.
And we're using
diffraction methods
to unravel the internal
structure-- in other words, how
the atoms are arranged
that make up that material.
What we derived from the
experiment are intensities.
So if you imagine
a wave, the height
of that wave as I'm
drawing it would
be what we call our intensity.
We can then work out, by the
same mathematics that they
used 100 years ago,
a Fourier series.
And it's the
Fourier series which
enables us to reconstruct
the electron density that's
inside that crystal.
And the peaks of the electron
density are the atoms.
And that is because we're
diffracting the x-rays
from the extra
nuclear electrons.
Instead of having to calculate
each Fourier layer slowly
by hand, plotting it out,
carefully with contours,
the structures now will
evolve before your eyes,
if you like, on a
computer screen.
Once you have the basic atomic
molecular structure, that
begins to open up any number
of avenues you can explore.
And of course, when we started,
at least when I started,
it took around about
a year to solve
relatively simple
molecular structure.
Now we can do several before
coffee in the morning.
And that's just in the lab.
I find the whole thing-- I
mean, the crystals themselves
are beautiful and pretty.
The diffraction
pattern is pretty.
Because if you
actually get spots,
then you've got a crystal.
You've got order.
You've got periodic order,
which means you have actually
got something you can work with.
So that's exciting, and
also, some of the patterns
are really lovely.
I started studying
the subject when
I was an undergraduate
student in the '60s.
And then I went
to Oxford to study
for my D.Phil with
Dorothy Hodgkin, the Nobel
Laureate and a huge
influence in my life.
Dorothy, of course, started
amazingly in 1934, '35,
to look at protein crystals.
They had no way of
solving the structures,
but they knew that if
they could get diffraction
from these crystals
that then some day,
they would eventually solve
the protein structures.
And Dorothy had an amazing
knack or intuition of,
first of all, choosing
the right problem
and then being able to solve it.
So she worked on Vitamin B12.
She worked on penicillin.
And the insulin crystals
which she had in fact taken
photographs of in
the end of 1934,
that structure was
not solved-- published
until 1969, which is
an amazing 35 years.
Today, people would
be expecting to solve
that in 35 days or less.
We can get to know more and
more about the structures
of the proteins, but
that's only the beginning.
It doesn't tell you how
they work necessarily.
And biology's just
amazingly complex.
I mean, the way we work.
And you work differently
from the way I
work, and the next
person and so on.
What's going on at
the molecular level?
I mean, we know a lot.
But there's plenty
more to find out.